[Musique]
le cimetière is right wintzenheim a ses
habitués depuis 40 ans lisent et robert
s'y rendent jusqu'à plusieurs fois par
semaine bien qu'il n'y ait aucune
famille en voisin bienveillant il y
réalise de petits travaux d'entretien et
s'assure que personne ne vienne troubler
le repos des défunts une histoire qui
commence en 1979 presque par hasard
lise nouvellement installés dans la rue
croise une amie au portail du cimetière
elle me dit pas ce match plutôt que fais
tu là et alors c'est à ce moment là
qu'elle m'a dit tiens tu pourrais
prendre les clés de ce cimetière
pas de problème et au printemps elle est
venue me voir et elle a dit pourri aussi
entretenir et c'est ce qu'on a accepté
sans réfléchir vraiment de bon coeur et
nous l'avons fait pendant 40 ans si au
début 19e siècle
wintzenheim compter la plus grande
communauté juive du département
aujourd'hui il n'y reste que deux
familles autrefois rural le judaïsme
s'est déplacé vers les villes ainsi
nombre de cimetières historique se
retrouve son gardien pour les tornare
venir en aide à la communauté était une
évidence
mon mari et moi on est des enfants des
héros du silence
nos deux parents étaient des résistants
mon mari a été orphelin à l'âge de deux
ans son père a été arrêté par la gestapo
donc c'était déjà la raison on était
attaché à beaucoup de choses
robert ayant vécu cette enfance
difficile comme les enfants juifs et
après il ya eu une grande amitié avec
des enfants juifs laventure bénévoles
dure depuis quatre décennies quand
monsieur et madame tornare reçoivent le
titre le payeur de mémoire ils font
partie depuis cet automne des 22 haut
rhinois chargé de veiller sur les
cimetières juifs des partenaires nous
avons dans le département veine de
cimetières dont une grande majorité où
il n'y a plus de communauté et donc pour
éviter des problèmes
en tout genre dans les cimetières le
département a proposé de créer cet
organisme de veilleurs de mémoire
reconnu par le département et donc c'est
l'élaboration de tout ce système qu'on a
mis en place derrière cette initiative
des veilleurs de mémoire la politique de
dialogue inter religieux du conseil
départemental pour l'institution il faut
oeuvrer à la bonne entente entre les
différents cultes
c'est l'objet de cette réunion qui se
tient dans la mairie de mulhouse
autour de la table des représentants de
différentes associations du dialogue
interreligieux et de différentes
religions
c'est une volonté de notre présidente
brigitte klinkert qui a souhaité réunir
en synergie tous les acteurs des
associations des groupes interreligieux
du département la première rencontre a
eu lieu le 1er juillet 2018
aujourd'hui on en est à notre cinquième
rencontre est donc bien on a toujours
cette envie de travailler ensemble de
toujours progresser
à l'origine de ce dialogue une certaine
idée de l alsace et du vivre ensemble
de tout temps différents cultes et
cultures ont cohabité sur notre
territoire
une diversité parfois à la source de
drames historiques mais surtout creusé
d'une proximité par delà les différences
le dialogue interreligieux c'est une
marque forte de notre identité
alsacienne et il faut la préserver il
faut promouvoir cette paix sociale la
fois apprendre à mieux se connaître à
être plus tolérants
l'un envers l'autre on est on est dans
l'accompagnement au quotidien au plus
proche des personnes qui y vivent des
relations interreligieuses le bien vivre
ensemble la lutte contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et toutes les tous les
signes de haine des autres
pour être pro actif dans le dialogue
inter religieux le conseil départemental
organise ces rencontres il mène
également des actions à destination des
collégiens a mis en place le dispositif
des veilleurs de mémoire un fonds de
soutien au dialogue interreligieux a
également été créé pour soutenir les
initiatives des cultes c'est un fonds
qui qui est destiné aux associations
pour leurs projets leurs initiatives
comme par exemple le festival du conte
ajar dyade interreligieux le calendrier
interreligieux
les conférences des rallyes photo donc
tout ce qu'il ya à faire à
l'interreligieux un petit coup de pouce
peut être donnée au niveau des
associations le conseil départemental
s'est engagé à soutenir toutes ces
initiatives nous sommes maintenant au
collège sainte jeanne d'arc 2012
aujourd'hui les élèves travaillent sur
l'histoire d'adélaïde ovale une femme
alsacienne qui reçu le titre de juste
parmi les nations
indigné par le sort fait aux juifs dans
la source de la seconde guerre mondiale
cette alsacienne protestante
n'appliquera jamais ses valeurs
humanistes même dans l'enfer des camps
de concentration c'est vraiment cette
notion d'humanité que dans des contextes
politiques qui sont très complexes avec
des situations très difficiles
il ya des gens qui se sont opposés à
certains régimes à certaines idéologies
à certains à certains principes qui
était posée comme étant des des constats
et qui ont été essayé de résister de
garder vraiment cette notion d'humanité
au coeur de leur vie
monté par le conseil départemental le
fonds social juif unifié l'église
protestante réformée d'alsace et de
lorraine ainsi que la fondation pour la
mémoire de la shoah
l'exposition est un exemple du dialogue
inter-religieux souhaité par
l'institution départementale
au travers des raids adélaïde hautval on
est à la fois dans la question de la
lutte contre l'antisémitisme
on est aussi au coeur du dialogue inter
religieux puisque elle était protestante
et elle est intervenue sur surtout parce
qu'elle était sur les toiles qu'elle
devait porter ami des juifs et 7
ce très fort message
au moment où disparaissent les derniers
témoins de la shoah les teams les
derniers témoins finances très fort
message nous voulons le porter aussi et
dans les départements alsaciens c'est un
souhait très fort de vouloir mettre en
avant ceux ci dont encore une fois des
départements qui connaissent une
diversité religieuse comme nulle part
ailleurs en france l'exposition adélaïde
hautval rencontre un grand succès dans
les collèges
une vingtaine d'établissements l'ont
déjà réservé